we begin this morning with President
Trump meeting Russian President Vladimir
Putin at the g20 economic summit in
Hamburg Germany for their first
face-to-face talks one of the topics of
discussion Russian meddling in last
year's presidential election Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson says mr. Trump
and mr. Putin agreed the allegations
have become a hindrance to better
relations between the US and Russia but
in the meeting mr. Putin reportedly
denied any meddling and accounts of
President Trump's response to that are
under dispute this morning thousands of
demonstrators are massing for a third
straight day of protests outside the g20
summit major Garrett is in Hamburg good
morning major
good morning until last night protests
against this g20 summit and economic
globalization which is at the heart of
its mission were mostly a sideshow
occasionally disruptive but little more
well that's changed and now German
police are bracing for the biggest
crowds yet and the prospect of still
more violence protests at the g20 raged
overnight fires and looting increased
the sense of chaos surrounding the
summit the German government summoned
reinforcements to confront an estimated
100,000 protesters expected to converge
on Hamburg for the summit's final day
so far more than 200 German police have
been injured and nearly 100 protesters
arrested or detained president Trump
referenced the disturbances and remarks
to German Chancellor Angela Merkel it's
been really incredible the way things
have been handled and nothing's easy to
follow the president also talked about
his lengthy meeting with Russian
President Vladimir Putin Rex and I had a
tremendous meeting yesterday mr. Trump
and Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
huddled with Putin and Russian Foreign
Minister Sergei Lavrov for 2 hours and
15 minutes the president raised but did
not press the issue of Russian meddling
in the 2016 election in an off-camera
briefing Tillerson said Putin denied
ordering as the US intelligence
community has concluded unprecedented
cyber attacks during the campaign the
president's rightly focused on how do we
move forward from what may be simply an
intractable disagreement at this point
on North Korea Tillerson said the US and
Russia also disagree about the immediacy
of the nuclear threat there is a
difference in terms of view around
tactics and pace and so we will continue
to work with them to see if we cannot
persuade them as to the urgency that we
see Democrats in Congress accused the
president of failing to stand up and
confront Putin about election
interference when asked to describe the
encounter russia's Foreign Minister said
mr. Trump quote accepted Putin's blanket
denial of election interference Dayna
major Garrett in Hamburg Germany major
thank you